[Music]
over the next five minutes we'll build a
simple JavaScript app then compile its
code for iOS Android Windows desktop Mac
OS and the web to make this possible
we'll be using a new library from the
ionic team called capacitor if you've
built hybrid apps in the past you're
probably familiar with Apache Cordova
which allows web technologies to
interact with native SDKs capacitor is a
replacement for Cordova that puts
progressive web apps on the same plane
field as native apps so you don't need
to constantly check which platform
you're on you just write your code once
and it should work across all platforms
if you're new here make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and if you're interested in
building cross-platform apps consider
upgrading to a pro membership to get
access to my ionic native with firebase
course before we get started I do need
to point out that capacitor is just an
alpha release at this point so it's not
stable enough to use in production and
it's API is likely to change in the
coming months and one other thing to
keep in mind is that this is a
standalone tool so you can use it with
any JavaScript framework or just plain
JavaScript if you wanted to for this
demo I'm using angular but not the ionic
version of angular just a plain CLI app
go ahead and open up the app in your IDE
and then install the capacitor CLI we
can just copy the command from the docs
and then run it from the terminal that
should install it in your project and at
the time of this video we're running
version 1.0 alpha 32 then next thing
we'll do is initialize our app by
running an NP X cap in it and you can
give the app name then the package ID is
important for mobile apps it should
follow a format of calm brand name dot
project name the only thing that's doing
at this point is adding this capacitor
config JSON file to the root of your
project you want to go in here and
change the web directory to dist because
an angular we compile our code to the
dist folder now let's make sure
everything's working properly by
building our app with ng build prod then
we'll serve the app with capacitor by
running NP x cap serve and that's going
to run it as a progressive web app in
the browser that should give you a
default angular app that looks something
like this everything looks good there so
we'll go ahead and delete all the
boilerplate code from the
component and we'll build out a feature
that requires interaction with native
SDKs a good specimen is geolocation data
web browsers have one implementation
while iOS and Android have their own
native SDK implementations but because
we're using capacitor we don't really
have to worry about that we write one
piece of logic and it ties all of these
different implementations together the
app we're building is nothing more than
a button that when clicked will show the
user their current Latin long position
and it shows that using an alert dialog
which also needs to be handled
differently based on the platform that
that code is running on the first thing
we'll do is go into the app component
and we'll set up a button here that runs
this show alert method when clicked now
switching over to the typescript will
import plugins from capacitor core that
brings in all the default plugins such
as camera keyboard etc then we have a
few things here from rxjs that we'll see
in use later in the code then we'll go
ahead and D structure the plugins just
to the ones we need which in this case
will be geolocation and modal's in case
you're not familiar with that syntax
it's just like saying plugins
geolocation or plugins modal's just a
little more concise the geolocation
plug-in that we're working with here
returns a stream of data so whenever the
user moves it's going to emit a new geo
position based on wherever they moved we
can listen to the position with that
callback function but because we're
working in an angular app it be better
to format that data as an observable so
I'll show you a little trick here to
convert a callback to an observable by
using bind call back from rxjs you pass
the function that would normally expect
a callback and then that's going to
create another function that returns an
observable so if you want to get the
observable you just call this function
and then you can pass in any arguments
that were expected by the original
function the end result is that this
watch variable is now an observable of
the geolocation data in this example
we're only interested in the latitude
and longitude so we'll pipe in the map
operator and further map that object
down to the actual coordinates and now
that we have a way of retrieving our
observable we'll go ahead and subscribe
to it during ng on a net whenever it
emits a value we'll use that value as
the coordinates property
on this component so now we have our
data in place the last thing we need to
do is create an event handler when the
user clicks that button to show them the
actual coordinate data first I'll set a
couple variables for latitude and
longitude and then we'll use the modal's
plugin to display a different alert
message based on the platform you'll
notice the message looks significantly
different based on the device that
triggers it so that's the entire code
for our app let's go ahead and do a
production build with ng built prod and
then we'll add Android as a platform by
running npx cap add Android this creates
an android folder in the root of the
project and if we open up this folder
with Android studio we can click the
play button and our app should run on a
native emulator notice that we get
prompted for permission and the alert
message looks significantly different
than our progressive web app building
for iOS is just as easy we follow the
same set of commands just replacing
Android with iOS and we get a build that
works on iPhones just two apps left
Windows and Mac OS we can build these
native desktop apps using electron so
run npx cap add electron that creates an
electron directory CD into that
directory and install electron packagers
so we can build the binaries for Windows
and Mac OS then running electron
packager and specify win32 for Windows
and Darwin for Mac OS and that'll put
our app on five different platforms just
in the nick of time if we look in the
folder is generated by electron we
should see one for Windows with an
executable file inside if we bring those
files over to a Windows machine and open
up the executable we should have an app
running on Windows just like it did on
all the other platforms so even though
it's very early to be using capacitor
it's something you want to have on your
radar because it could potentially
change the way hybrid apps are built in
a very big way I'm gonna wrap things up
there if you have any questions get in
touch with me on slack otherwise make
sure to subscribe to the channel and if
you're serious about building native
apps consider upgrading to a pro
membership and taking the fully on it
course you'll get access to a whole
ecosystem of resources designed to help
you build your app faster
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon